bonsoir alexis poulain mercier voilà
vous êtes indigne de la boue tout seul
merci d'être avec nous 17 novembre 2010
8 17 novembre 2020 donc deux ans que
gilet jaune et pourquoi
finalement quel est le bilan aujourd'hui
alors c'est un bilan extrêmement amer
finalement de cette incroyable épopée
sociale qui a révélé les extrêmes
inégalités les risques qui était ce que
faisait courir ces politiques d'
emmanuel macron mais aussi la marche du
monde à la société française et gilet
jaune
ils ont été il y a deux ans les canaris
de la mine ceux qui ont alerté sur ce
risque grandissant de la paupérisation
de la précarisation d'une partie
importante de la classe moyenne qui est
pourtant un des socles de notre société
et de la république française c'était un
cri de protestation d'abord sur
l'augmentation d'une taxe taxe carbone
qui faisait que le carburant s'envolait
et ont touché la au porte-monnaie des
gens qui avaient besoin de la voiture
pour aller travailler et qui est bien
avec du mal à finir la fin de mois alors
qu'ils étaient intégrés qu'ils
travaillaient et qu'ils pensent être les
gagnants de cette mondialisation qu'on
avait vendu comme étant heureuse or ils
se sont avérés être les perdants et
lycées de contestation est très vite
tombé dans la colère face au refus de
vouloir entendre
rappelez vous les premiers commentaires
moqueurs qui avait été fait c'est gilet
jaune fumeurs de klopp qui roulent au
diesel et sert à la morgue d'edouard
philippe et du gouvernement face à cette
contestation sociale qu'il ne comprenait
pas tout simplement puisque c'était
normal de payer une taxe carbone ça
allait dans le bon sens pour l'écologie
et il ya eu là la prise des ronds points
c'est zéro point ces zones périurbaines
où vivait nombre de gilet jaune où ils
ont commencé à se rassembler à découvrir
la solidarité à voir que finalement le
nombre comptait que ce gilet jaune ce
symbole des déclassés de ce qu'ils font
le travail quotidien invisible les
invisibles se rendaient visible avec ce
gilet jaune et c'était assez formidable
dans les premiers mois il faut savoir
que entre le 17 novembre il 21 décembre
quand même une dizaine de morts sur ces
barrages routiers gilet jaune et et
autres confondues et puis ensuite il ya
eu la rue les manifestations tous les
samedis les actes
petit à petit et la lutte qui était
celle du pouvoir d'achat est devenu
finalement un mouvement citoyen qui
demandait une autre démocratie face à la
confiscation du pouvoir qui étaient
faites par les élites auto proclamées et
alexis poulain une réparation évidemment
s'en sont bien d'une violente ce qu'on
peut qualifier d'inédite oui c'est la
seule réponse qui a été apportée
finalement sous couvert bien sûr de
protéger les commerces les bons citoyens
de la violence un de ces gilet jaune vu
comme violent il faut se rappeler que
les premières manifestations étaient
unitaire et que les gilets jaunes
applaudissait la police les remercier et
leur demandait d'ailleurs de se joindre
à eux puisqu'ils étaient d'une certaine
façon à eux aussi porter de gilet jaune
et quelle a été la réponse du pouvoir
très rapidement très rapidement
ça a été une répression sanglante d'une
violence inouïe
les comptes font peur ils ne sont pas
encore terminées puisqu'on est à deux
ans mais david dufresne le journaliste
allait faire un décompte avec son compte
à l'eau place beauvau c'est plus de 4400
aux blessés et 24 qui ont été épargnées
qui ont perdu un oeil certains étaient
des figures du mouvement comme jérôme
rodriguez et cinq qui ont eu la main
arrachée côté du des forces de l'ordre
place beauvau faisait état de 1944
blessés et on a vu finalement la
violence et la répression d'état se
mettre en place d'une manière inédite
jusqu'à présent simplement pour faire
taire cette répression qu'on ne voulait
pas entendre
et quand c'était impossible de continuer
parce qu'il aurait fallu tuer des gens
la violence montant chaque fois d'un
cran
le lanceur de balles de défense est une
arme de guerre il faut voir la façon
dont la répression a été organisée par
parle
nouvelle doctrine mise en place par
christophe castaner alors miser
l'intérieur est aussi edouard philippe
le premier ministre il a fallu quand
même arrêter ou temporiser
emmanuel macron a sorti de sa poche la
carte du grand débat l'idée c'était de
faire croire que les revendications
celles des citoyens le leur à le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne la
volonté de parler les cahiers de
doléances qui avait été écrit au beau
père ont des mairies tout cela était
mise en scène dans la parole et et la
geste présidentiel qui a monopolisé le
débat
tout simplement en se mettant en scène
dans le cadre de la campagne des
européennes
ce grand débat qui a coûté plusieurs
millions d'euros aux contribuables a
permis à emmanuel macron finalement de
faire croire que le dialogue était
enclenché à mener que les gilet jaune or
les salle était remplie d'un public trié
sur le volet et gilet jaune était il
sait bien bien à l'écart et finalement
de dialogue il n'y eut pas venu que ce
faux grand débat alors que les gilets
jaunes avaient organisé un vrai débat
qu'ils avaient écrit leurs
revendications qui étaient déjà recensés
sur les cahiers de doléances donc voilà
la vraie arnaque d'une certaine façon ou
le coup de poker des modèles macron qui
a refusé finalement de parler au gilet
jaune et qui s'est mis lui en scène
faisant semblant de parler au peuple
français et la question évidemment lexie
est-ce que les gilet jaune ont disparu
non certainement pas alors certes ils
ont été rendues invisibles par les lois
de répression d'interdiction quasiment
des manifestations il y avait ces images
alors on n'a plus droit maintenant de
filmer les forces de l'anp si jamais la
la la la loi de sécurité globale passée
mais où un crs essayé d'exploser avec sa
botte un ballon de baudruche jaune tout
ce qu'il y avait la couleur jaune
finalement devenait séditieux comme
disait christophe castaner à l'époque
donc on a très vite compris les
manifestants qu'il fallait enlever les
gilet jaune mais aimer ça ne veut pas
dire que les revendications premières
des gilet jaune les craintes première
des gilles et jo nommé colère qui était
celle de ne pas être entendu de ne pas
être écoutés de devoir des politiques
publiques qui les oubliés
systématiquement ceux là sont toujours
là bien présent et je pense que les
rangs n'ont fait que gonfler
même si la rue s'est vidée par crainte
simplement d'une blessure parce que tout
vu la violence dont était capable ce
gouvernement est bien la contestation
elle est toujours présente et elle est
même les sondeurs en sont très
conscients jusqu'à un dernier sondage
qui était sorti de fondapol en octobre
faisait état de 79 % des électeurs qui
envisage un vote anti système en 2022
c'est à dire un barrage finalement anti
macron de voter tout sauf les partis en
place et particulièrement la république
en marche ça voudrait dire huit
électeurs sur dix qui qui préférait le
vote blanc l'abstention ou un vote anti
système en 2022 donc c'est dire comment
finalement c'est de cette colère et
cette défiance vis-à-vis des pouvoirs
publics n'a fait qu'augmenter et puis
arrive par dessus la crise du
coronavirus crises sanitaires
extrêmement mal gérée depuis le mois de
mars et on voit aujourd'hui les
commerçants qui n'étaient pas gilet
jaune puisque je devais fermer boutique
tous les samedis et qui se retrouvaient
sur le pavé à les regarder passer c'est
à dire et si je moi même j'étais
finalement un gilet jaune si j'étais le
prochain sur la liste le prochain des
perdants de cette politique et la
crainte je pense aujourd'hui du
gouvernement qui va faire beaucoup de
chèques et essayer de subventionner
autant que faire se peut des secteurs
qu'ils ferment les uns après les autres
c'est d'éviter que les commerçants se
joignent au gilet jaune et que grandisse
ce mouvement qui n'a pas trouvé
finalement d'aboutissement politique
mais tout ça n'est pas fini malgré
l'entrisme des partis politiques je
crois que il ya une intelligence
politique de ce mouvement citoyen des
gilet jaune qui a refusé la récupération
et qui a décidé de s'auto organiser et
aujourd'hui université citoyenne
grand rendez-vous les gilet jaune
continue d'être actif politiquement de
se politiser et de chercher finalement
une sortie une issue pour rendre
finalement la démocratie est le pouvoir
au peuple pour qu'il soit gouvernée par
le peuple et pour le peuple
ce qui est loin d'être le cas
aujourd'hui merci alexis poulain jeu